يعني انا ليش فتحت السوشيال ميديا كانت
عشان الناس يسالوني انا كفيفه اغلب الناس
متواصلون معي على الواتساب يتوقعون انه
لازم بس يسجلوا لي فويس مسجز
[موسيقى]
يعني هون في بالهم ان الشخص الكبير خلاص
يقعد في البيت وما يسوي شيء حتى في بعض
الناس كيف تروحين السينما لا والله ما
يعني
كيف يعني كيف اروح السينما يعني ترى اسمع
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
اكثر مشكله طبعا تواجهني انه اذا كان معاي
مرافق
فيكلمون المرافق ما يكلموني بحجه اني انا
كفيفه فيعني كاني ما بعرف ارده فهذا للاسف
شيء يعني يزعلني يعني ليش ما تكلمونا بس
في النهايه يعني
تعلمت اني انا اتكلم يعني خلاص اذا هم
كلموني انا اتكلم لان انا عندي قاعده تقول
باذا تشينج ذاتي وانت يعني يعني انا اللي
اكون التغيير اللي انا بشوفه في العالم
بدخل المطبخ لاول مره اليوم يا بخاطري اني
اسوي كوفي سويت التحديات اللي نحن نواجهها
مكفوفين بشكل عام يعني كل يوم انا انا
يعني اعتبر هذا
التحدي انجاز صغير نحن نحاول نطلع له حل
التحديات
كثيره بس لقينا لها حلول الحمد لله كل
مشكله تواجهنا نلاقي حل مثلا نستخدم برامج
في التلفون تخبرنا الالوان في برنامج
نقدر نكلم متطوع من خلال يقدر يساعدنا في
اغلب الاشياء الموجوده باستخدام الكاميرا
بدايتي مع الرسم كانت في 2018
[موسيقى]
بديتها مع
انا شفوف بتعليم الاطفال المكفوفين
الخطوات اللي انا تساعدني ان انا اعلم
الاطفال في البدايه في اي ورشه انه في
البدايه احط الادوات
امامهم بشكل مرتب وابدا اشرح لكرين طفل
على حقه كوينا كفيف شو الادوات اللي
يستخدمها فمثلا
الاحجار مثلا على
اليمين مثلا الالوان في النص ونحدد له
مثلا شو الالوان اللي هي موجوده
[موسيقى]
وجودي في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولنشر
الوعي عن فئه المكفوفين وعشان حسابي يوصل
لاي ام عندها طفل كفيف تعرف ان الحياه ما
توقف لمجرد بس انه طفلك كف بصره وحتى
الكبار من المكفوفين تزيد الثقه بنفسهم
[موسيقى]
طبعا انا توصلني الحمد لله كثير من
المسجات اللي يشكرون في الفيديوهات وحسيت
بفرق وكثيرين يعني توصلني مسجات منهم ان
يقولوا لنا يقولوا لي انه انت شجعتيني ان
انا استخدم العصا وبفضلك انا بديت
استخدمها فالحمد لله
رسالتي الكل اللي يشوفون الاشخاص
المكفوفين لا تحكم على الشخص لان كفيف بس
لمجرد انه كفيف لازم تعطيه فرصه تشوف
قدراته تشوف هل هو يقدر يسوي شيء ولا لا
[موسيقى]